Prof: So today we're
going to start talking about
classical utilitarianism,
and we're going to use as our
point of departure Jeremy
Bentham,
who lived between 1748 and 1832
and came up with the canonical
statement of the doctrine of
utilitarianism.
It's a doctrine which is still
very much alive and kicking in
the contemporary West despite
all of its problems,
and we'll have things to say
about why that is.
But I wanted to make a couple
of prefatory remarks first about
Bentham himself.
There are some thinkers in the
Western tradition,
I guess in any tradition,
who have a particular
characteristic that Bentham
certainly has,
and I think of the folks we're
going to read Karl Marx had and
Robert Nozick had.
And the thing I'm thinking of
here is they are the kind of
person who takes one idea to the
most extreme possible
formulation.
They ask themselves a question,
"How would the world be if
this idea that I have is the
only important idea,"
and they take it to its logical
extreme,
to an excessive kind of
formulation.
And they will go places with
their idea that nobody else will
go, and so that makes them a
little bit crazy.
They're monomaniacal,
obsessively consumed with their
idea.
In the case of Bentham it's the
idea of utility,
which we're going to unpack a
little bit in a moment.
But what's always interesting
about people like this is that
they play out an idea to its
logical extreme and that
exhibits both its strengths and
its limitation just because
they're willing to go when
others will not go,
think the unthinkable,
think politically incorrect
things for their time in pursuit
of really pushing this idea to
the absolute hilt.
And so Bentham is the kind of
thinker who I suspect,
at the end of the day,
nobody will be fully convinced
by, but he's very useful.
He's a very useful
diagnostician of what it is
about utilitarianism that's
going to be appealing to you and
where eventually you're going to
want to put some limits on it
just because he goes beyond the
limits.
And so you can see what happens
if you push it all the way to
the hilt.
Secondly, I want to just say
that Bentham is important as a
fountain of more than
utilitarianism,
but also of modern conceptions
of value more generally
considered.
You'll see that there were
rumblings of the kinds of things
he had to say about value in the
seventeenth century.
Hobbes, for example,
who I mentioned last time,
criticized Aristotle for not
seeing that what is good for
some people may not be good for
other people,
and Bentham builds on that idea.
You'll see Bentham will start
to link the good to what it is
that people desire.
There were also rumblings of
Bentham's methods in
particularly his aspirations to
found politics on scientific
principles in the seventeenth
century.
We already saw last time the
Hobbesian and Lockean
creationist theories of science,
but they were really
transitional figures.
They also gave theological
justifications for their
arguments as I explained at some
length in Locke,
in the context of Locke.
I didn't have time to do it
with Hobbes,
but many of you will know that
if you read the second
two-thirds of Hobbes'
Leviathan, it's almost
all about interpretation of the
scriptures,
showing that his scientifically
derived principles are also
consistent with the Bible.
Bentham sheds all of this.
For Bentham he's not interested
in appeals to tradition.
He's not interested in appeals
to religion.
to natural law.
He dismisses the natural law
tradition as dangerous nonsense,
"nonsense on stilts."
He's only interested in a
scientific set of principles for
organizing politics.
And one of the nice things
about Bentham,
at least from your point of
view, is--
and we'll see that
utilitarianism values efficiency
in many ways,
but one of the interesting
things or the helpful things
about Bentham is that he reduces
his whole doctrine to a single
paragraph,
and he puts that paragraph
right at the front of his
Introduction to The
Principles of Morals and
Legislation.
So here you have the kind of
Cliffs Notes formulation of
Bentham's argument.
He says that,
"Nature has placed mankind
under the governance of two
sovereign masters,
pain and pleasure.
It is for them alone to point
out what we ought to do,
as well as to determine what we
shall do."
So this is going to be about
describing human behavior and
about what ought to be the case,
right?
What we shall do.
...[T]o point out what we ought
to do as well as to determine
what we shall do.
On the one hand the standard of
right and wrong,
on the other the chain of
causes and effects,
are fastened to their throne.
(That's the throne of pain and
pleasure.)
They govern us in all we do,
in all we say,
and in all we think:
every effort we can make to
throw off our subjection (that's
our subjection to
pleasure-seeking and
pain-avoiding) will serve but to
demonstrate and confirm it (to
confirm that subjection).
In words a man may pretend to
abjure their empire (that's the
empire of pain and pleasure):
but in reality he will remain
subject to it all the while.
The principle of utility
recognizes this subjection,
and assumes it for the
foundation of that system,
the object of which is to rear
the fabric of felicity by the
hands of reason and law.
Systems which attempt to
question it deal in sounds
instead of sense,
in caprice instead of reason,
and in darkness instead of
light.
That is, in a nutshell,
Bentham's theory;
very bold unequivocal statement.
He's saying if you want to
understand human beings in a
causal explanatory sense all you
have to know about them is that
they're going to seek pleasure
and avoid pain.
And if you want to think about
what ought to happen in the
design of institutions they
should be designed around that
fact, to accommodate that fact.
And he's going to develop a
system of laws,
a system of government that
takes into account and is built
upon this assumption about human
nature,
as he would have called it;
human psychology,
as we would call it today.
Now, I'm going to make five
points about Bentham's system to
give you some sense of the full
dimensions of it,
before we start dissecting it
and subjecting it to critical
scrutiny.
I want to make sure that we
understand exactly what his
system is.
And I want to first of all
notice that it is what I'm going
to call a comprehensive and
deterministic account.
I call it a comprehensive and
deterministic account in that
it's an account of all human
behavior.
He wants to say everything you
do is ultimately determined by
pleasure-seeking and
pain-avoiding.
How plausible--who thinks
that's plausible?
Hands up.
Plausible?
Implausible?
Okay, give us an example,
somebody,
of something that is not
pleasure-seeking or
pain-avoiding,
anybody, something that is not
the result of pleasure-seeking
or pain-avoiding.
Well, you put your hands up.
You must have had some thoughts.
Yeah, okay here.
Yeah, you take it.
Student: Running into a fire to
rescue people.
Prof: Pardon?
Student:  Running into a
fire to rescue people.
Prof: Running into a
Okay, you run into a fire to
rescue people.
What do you think Bentham would
say about that example?
Yeah, over here, sir.
Student:  The pleasure
is actually saving the people,
so there is,
like, this benefit that you get
from it, the pleasure.
Prof: The pleasure you
get from having saved the people
must outweigh the pain of the
fire or you wouldn't do it.
Any other example?
Nobody's got an example?
Nobody can think of an example?
No?
Yes? Yes, sir?
Student:  Well,
there may be some.
For example,
saving one's child may be
purely instinctual rather than
driven by pain or pleasure.
Prof: So say sacrificing
your life to save your child,
let's say, to put it in an
extreme case.
Student:  Yes.
Prof: What would Bentham
say about that?
I mean, this seems like a
genuine altruistic action.
Somebody lays down their life
for their own child.
How can that be
pleasure-seeking and
pain-avoiding?
What would Bentham say?
Yeah?
Student:
>
Prof: Wait,
we need you...
Student:  I mean,
clearly the pain of,
like, having lost a child,
like, outweighs whatever
pleasures.
Prof: Yeah,
I think that is what he would
say.
Think of the counterfactual.
How could I live with myself
for the rest of my life if I
didn't do it?
The pain would be too great.
And Bentham considers cases
like this sort of thing.
Apparently altruistic acts
seems ultimately always
reducible to the pleasure-pain
calculus.
One example he considers is
people acting from religious
motivations and he says,
"Ha!
Just read the Bible.
Look at the descriptions of
heaven and hell.
Isn't that a made-to-order
pleasure-seeking and
pain-avoidance?"
Hell is described as,
you know, the fires of hell,
perpetual pain.
So, the people who constructed
religious doctrines clearly had
an understanding of human nature
or they wouldn't have described
hell in a way that they
described it and heaven in the
way that they describe it.
So, the first thing he wants to
say is that this is a completely
comprehensive explanation of
human behavior.
Can anybody think of any
example that couldn't be
re-described as fitting this
pleasure-pain calculus?
Yeah?
Student:  I think that
if life is all about pain and
pleasure we would be willing to
replace our life with one with
only,
I mean, one only with pleasure,
right?
But we wouldn't.
We value our life by ourself.
There is something
indescribable quality to it.
I mean, life is the sum of all
experiences rather than just
pain and pleasure,
so.
Prof: So you think that
there is more complexity to
human motivation that's just not
expressible as or reducible to
pain and pleasure.
I think that's a very
sophisticated and common
critique that's been made of
Bentham.
If you go and read,
indeed if you read the obituary
of him that was written by
Coleridge, I think it was,
makes exactly this point.
There was this sophistication
to human motivation that isn't
captured in this idea.
I think that the truth is
Bentham would have acknowledged
some of that,
but he would have said,
"At the end of the day
it's not important because the
pleasure-pain calculus overrides
when the chips are down.
If we're going to think about
what it is that's going to
motivate people,
it's pleasure-seeking and
pain-avoidance."
Okay, a second thing that you
should notice about this
doctrine is that I'm going to
call it a naturalistic doctrine.
In some ways it's astounding
that writing almost half a
century before Darwin,
Darwin was born in 1809 and
lived until 1882,
so writing almost half a
century before Darwin,
Bentham grounds his principle
in the imperatives for human
survival.
He thinks that the
pleasure-pain principle has a
natural biological basis.
Although there are religious,
moral and political sources and
sanctions of pain and pleasure,
these are all secondary to the
physical sources for Bentham.
"The physical,"
he refers to at one point,
as "the groundwork"
of the political,
moral, and religious.
It is included in each of them.
At another point he says we are
bound by the principle of
utility as "the natural
constitution of the human
frame" often unconsciously
and often when our conscious
explanations for our actions are
inconsistent with the principle
of utility.
I'll come back to that point.
If we didn't abide by the
principle of utility,
he says in his little essay,
The Psychology of Economic
Man,
he says, "The human
species could not continue in
existence and that in a few
months,
not to say weeks or days,
we would be all that would be
needed for its
annihilation."
In other words,
the principle of utility
expresses our objective
interests as living creatures.
A third point that I'm going to
make about Bentham's doctrine is
that it's what I will call
egoistic, but not subjectivist.
Now, that's a lot of babble
terminology, but let me explain
what it means.
The reason I'm using those two
words together is that they
don't normally go together.
That is to say egoistic views
are usually subjectivist,
so I'm pointing out that
they're not.
And by egoistic I mean it is
just like in all economics
assumptions, the assumption of
self-interest.
People are self-interested
seekers after pleasure,
and self-interested avoiders of
pain in exactly the way you
learn about them in an economics
101 textbook.
And we'll have occasion to
examine that self-interested
premise in some depth later.
But it's not a subjectivist
doctrine in that Bentham wants
to say this is true regardless
of what we ourselves say about
our preferences.
It's not dependent upon your
acknowledging its truth for its
being true, okay?
So you might think you're
motivated by altruism,
or love of your child,
or your religious faith.
Bentham says,
"You're just muddled and
deluded.
You don't understand.
Your subjective understanding
is not in accord with the
science of the matter."
At one point he says,
"It is with the anatomy of
the human mind as it is with the
anatomy and physiology of the
human body.
The rare case is not of a man's
being unconversant,
but of his being conversant
with it."
So just as if you have a pain
in your side and you don't know
if it's your liver,
or your spleen,
or your lung,
the rare case is you get it
right.
He once says exactly the same
with your motivation.
The fact that you don't
understand, or wouldn't agree
with, or don't acknowledge
what's motivating you,
so much the worse for you.
You just have an inaccurate or
incomplete understanding of your
motivation.
You're just wrong, okay?
So it's in that sense picks up
on the idea this is an
objectivist account.
It is objectively the case.
Whatever people think about it,
whatever people say about it,
it is objectively the case that
they behave self interestedly in
the pursuit of pleasure and the
avoidance of pain.
Fourth, Bentham's is a
radically consequentialist
doctrine.
Anyone know what that might
mean?
Anyone want to tell us what you
think I might mean by calling it
a consequentialist doctrine?
Yeah? Yes, ma'am?
Student:  That in being
motivated by pleasure and pain
we're concerned with the
consequences of our actions.
If we know something is going
to be painful we'll avoid it,
and if it's going to be
pleasurable we'll move towards
it.
Prof: Yeah,
but as I said at the beginning
of the lecture,
Bentham takes everything to the
extreme.
So we are concerned with the
consequences of the action and
nothing else.
It's an extreme
consequentialist doctrine.
He's not interested in our
intentions, right?
The road to hell is paved with
good intentions for Bentham.
Now, it doesn't matter what
people intend it matters what
happens, right?
It's a radically
consequentialist doctrine.
We will see that there's an
alternative tradition of
thinking about ethics and
politics that is deeply rooted
in human intentions when we come
to read Robert Nozick and John
Rawls and people who draw on
Kant's,
Immanuel Kant's ethics,
and that's what gets to you--
to give you all of the jargon
up front that is what will be
called deontological,
sometimes contrasted with
teleological.
Consequentialist is a kind of
teleological doctrine.
What does teleological
mean?
Anybody?
Yeah, at the back.
Teleological system?
Student:  Well,
given that telos in
Greek is the end...
Prof: The end,
the purpose,
the consequence,
exactly right.
So consequentialist doctrines
are teleological doctrines.
They're all about the
consequences,
the purpose,
the ends, the goals,
the results,
whereas what we will talk about
later when we get to
deontological systems,
or the antithesis of that,
they focus on intentions,
on processes,
on procedures,
on how you do things,
not on where you get to, okay?
So Bentham is a radical
consequentialist,
and you judge a doctrine simply
by looking,
you judge a possible policy,
an action,
anything you're thinking of
doing or not doing simply by
virtue of what effect it is
likely to have and nothing else.
Nothing else matters.
Finally, Bentham thinks
everything he's doing is
quantifiable.
I gave you just a sliver to
read from his Introduction to
the Principles of Morals and
Legislation just so that you
could get a sense of how this
guy's mind actually worked.
He really thought it was the
case that he could develop a
kind of science of
utilitarianism where he would
figure out exactly how many
utils,
we might call them.
We might call them Standard
International Utils,
"SIUs,"
would attach to a pleasure or
pain any policy or action,
and that eventually you could
figure out exactly what all of
the optimal policies were for
the organization of society.
He thought about utility.
He thought it had really four
dimensions.
How intense is it?
Duration, how long does it last?
Its certainty or uncertainty,
that is, probability that the
result will occur.
And what he called propinquity
or remoteness,
which modern economists would
say we discount pleasure into
the future.
If you say, "I'll give you
a dollar today,
or I'll give you a dollar
tomorrow,"
you'll get more utility from
the dollar that you get today,
okay?
So he thought that these were
all quantifiable dimensions of
utility,
so a little unsure about the
intensity,
but he's sure that everything
else can be quantified.
And he set about quantifying.
He set about trying to figure
out a system of legislation not
only for his society,
by the way, he started writing
constitutions for other
countries.
And when he ran off to Poland
and various places and said,
"Look, here's my
utilitarian constitution for
your country,"
and he was very disappointed
when people didn't rush off and
implement it right away.
So he truly believed that you
could come up with a
scientifically demonstrable
system of organizing society
based on the quantifiable
character of utilitarianism.
So one further feature of this
quantifiable character of
utilitarianism is that he
thought we could make
comparisons across people.
We could do the math across
people.
We could add up how much
utility one person gets from a
possible action,
and how much utility or
disutility another person gets,
and redistribute in order to do
what he thought we should do,
which was to maximize the
greatest happiness of the
greatest number.
He's a complete
consequentialist,
so we would do whatever we have
to do to maximize the greatest
happiness of the greatest
number.
So, for example,
I happen to know that Denise,
who's sitting over there,
has got a great capacity for
utility.
She's easily pleased.
If you give her a book she'll
be just delighted.
But Anthony over there is a
kind of grumpy guy.
If you give him a book he'd
say, "Well,
why didn't you give me two
books?
One measly book."
So, if I have a choice between
giving this book to Denise,
or giving the book to Anthony,
I'm going to give the book to
Denise because she's going to
get more utility than Anthony's
going to get from having this
book.
We don't really care who has
the utility from a social
perspective.
We want to maximize the
greatest happiness of the
greatest number,
okay?
But then what we might discover
is that Leonid over there has an
even greater capacity for
utility.
He is just a utility monster.
He's got such a capacity for
happiness that any little thing
that most of us would think is
neither here nor there is really
going to make him happy.
Well, then we should give
everything to him,
right?
So it's a doctrine that's
completely uninterested in the
distributive side of
utilitarianism except in an
instrumental way,
and we'll come back to that on
next Monday.
All you want to do is maximize
the greatest happiness of the
greatest number in society,
the total amount of happiness.
Now, here's a further feature
of Bentham's doctrine and I
think it follows from the
consequentialism that you should
at least notice,
because I think it bears on our
thinking about,
for instance,
the Eichmann problem.
And this is actually taken from
Robert Nozick's book,
who you're going to read later
in the semester,
in his critique of
utilitarianism.
He says let's consider the
following thought experiment.
Suppose your brain was
connected by electrodes to a
computer and the computer was
programmed to make you have
whatever experiences give you
pleasure and not to have any
experiences that give you pain.
So you would,
in fact, be unconscious,
I think actually in Nozick's
example,
floating in a vat unconscious,
but you would believe you were
doing whatever it is that gives
you the greatest pleasure.
And the question Nozick asked
is, "Would you want to be
connected to the machine?"
Who would want to be connected
to the machine?
Okay, we only have one,
two three, four,
five, six, seven,
eight, nine,
ten, fifteen.
I see about fifteen candidates
for Nozick's pleasure machine.
Who would not want to be
connected to this machine?
Okay, we have probably
two-thirds of you.
Who's not sure?
Okay, some are not sure.
Those who wouldn't want to be
connected, why not?
I mean, this is great, isn't it?
You don't have to work anymore.
You don't have to do
assignments.
You don't have to show up to
class.
You just, you know,
for the rest of your life,
maybe, you're programmed to
have the experiences that give
you the most pleasure in life.
What could be better than that?
Why don't you want to do it?
Yeah, over here?
Student:  Well,
I think the point of life is to
have like a complexity of
experiences,
and without experiencing pain
at some point pleasure wouldn't
be as sweet.
Prof: Okay,
the point of life is to--hold
on to the mic.
I just want to follow this a
little.
The point of life is to have
some contrast effects.
Richard Nixon said,
"Only if you've been in
the deepest valley can you
appreciate the joy of being on
the highest mountain,"
as he was being run out of the
Whitehouse in 1974.
Well, you could say,
okay, well, in that case we'll
program the machine accordingly
so you'll have certain painful
experiences in order to maximize
the net of pleasure and pain.
Every, I don't know,
every fifth minute you'll have
some unpleasant experience just
so that you don't forget how
pleasant the pleasant experience
is.
We can do that.
Student:  Well,
then you wouldn't be,
like, having free will in
experiencing the various
experiences.
Prof: Okay,
so that's different.
It's not the contrast.
It's not the banality of
pleasure, if you like,
it's that the lack of free will
or autonomy.
But couldn't we program it to
make you think you were acting
freely even though you weren't?
I think--what about that?
Some people say that's true of
us all, this idea we have free
will it's a lot of bunk.
We're all really basically just
acting out sort of impulses and
instincts, but we believe we
have free will.
So you could be made to believe
that you're making choices even
if, in fact, you aren't.
Student:  Well,
wouldn't the,
like, free will be as much a
component of,
like, the natural physical
nature of man...
Prof: Well now you're...
Student:  As well as--I
mean, I'm adding more to
Bentham, but...
Prof: Okay,
so that would be a different
theory than Bentham's theory,
but you can see where this is
going, right?
That I think there are some
people in the room,
if we had time to pursue this
conversation,
there are some people in the
room who no matter what you did
to the programming in the
experience machine they wouldn't
like it,
and they wouldn't like it for
two principle reasons,
I think.
One has just been articulated
which is that somehow this seems
like an abdication of your own
autonomy.
And when we think back to the
Eichmann problem one of the
things that troubled people was
his abdication of his autonomy.
He's giving up his free will to
say, "Yes or no.
I think this is right or wrong.
I'm going to do it on the basis
of my own autonomous
judgment."
The second thing I think that
people would worry about is
who's operating the machine.
Who's operating the machine?
How do you know that once
they've got you floating in that
vat what you wanted to have done
will in fact happen?
And so there's a basic problem
of agency and accountability
that makes people nervous.
But let's just put those things
to one side for the moment and
focus on the rest of the
exposition of Bentham's
doctrine.
We're going to come back to all
of these issues,
I promise you.
I just want to get everything
out on the table.
What he says is that the role
of government is,
"A measure of government
(which is but a particular kind
of action,
performed by a particular
person or persons) may be said
to be comfortable to or dictated
by the principle of utility when
in like manner the tendency
which it has to augment the
happiness of the community is
greater than any which it has to
diminish it."
So again, the bumper sticker
version of that for Bentham is,
maximize the greatest happiness
of the greatest number.
And for those of you who like
thinking diagrammatically,
and as I noted in my opening
lecture not everybody does,
but if we imagine a two-person
society,
so A has this much utility,
that's the status quo,
right?
A has this much utility.
B has that much utility,
and let's say there's some
outer limit of possible utility,
which we'll call the
possibility frontier.
Bentham would say if you draw
that line there anything that
puts us in this,
whatever it is,
cloudy zone here,
would be a net increase in the
total amount of utility in the
society;
pretty straight-forward claim,
right?
So we went from there to there.
Both would have more utility,
but if we went from there,
say, to there A's utility would
have gone up and B's would have
gone down,
but we don't care,
right, because the total amount
of utility in this society has
gone up.
What we wouldn't want to do is
come anywhere into this area
because then utility,
the total amount of utility in
this society would have
decreased.
Okay, so that's basically the
story.
Now, you might say,
"Well, why do you need
government at all if this is the
story?"
Everybody is--whatever they
think, whatever they say,
whatever they understand,
everybody is a mindless
pleasure-seeker and
pain-avoider,
or perhaps mindful
pleasure-seeker or pain-avoider,
but they have no control over
that.
They're going to just do what
they have to do.
Why create government with the
principle that it should
maximize utility in this
society?
It seems like an odd thing to
do.
Why would you do that?
Anyone? Yeah?
Student:  So just
looking at that last graph,
right?
If each person tried to
maximize their utility then
they'd both want to be on the
opposite corners of each other,
so then you would get chaos
when you extrapolate that to a
larger group.
You need something to kind of
manage everybody's pleasure,
I guess.
Prof: So people wouldn't
voluntarily do things that
maximize one another's--maximize
the total social utility,
right?
If taking something from A and
giving it to B would increase
B's utility more than it would
diminish A's utility,
well A's not going to go for
that voluntarily.
B might go and take it,
but he may or may not be strong
enough to take it.
We don't know.
So that's a very shrewd
observation in response to that
diagram,
and it actually gets to more
sophisticated questions about
redistribution and
utilitarianism that I'm going to
take up on Monday.
But there's,
I think, before we get to those
questions,
there's a more fundamental
level at which Bentham thinks
utilitarianism creates the need
for government,
and that is that there's a
disconnect between what's
individually optimal and what's
socially optimal even before we
get to the redistributive
questions.
We might call it the market
failure theory of government.
Where other eighteenth-century
thinkers had taken the view that
when this,
you know, Adam Smith's famous
invisible hand,
everybody acting selfishly
leads to a collectively optimal
result.
Bentham, we'll see,
thinks that's true a lot of the
time, but not always.
There are certain circumstances
in which people are likely not
to act in a way that produces a
common result.
"The great enemies of
public peace are the selfish and
dissocial passions--
necessary as they are...Society
is held together only by the
sacrifices that men can be
induced to make of the
gratifications they demand:
to obtain these sacrifices is
the great difficulty,
the great task of
government."
And he's thinking really of,
and this may be the first
formulation of it that we find,
what we today call free-riding,
freeloading.
He thinks about the provision
of something like national
defense, what we call,
economists call a public good.
You can't be excluded from the
benefits of it,
right, and it must be jointly
supplied.
So it says, If,
for example,
the commencement or continuing
of a war being the question upon
the carpet,
if, upon his calculation,
a hundred a-year during the
continuance of the war,
or for ever,
will be the amount of the
contribution which according to
his calculation he will have to
pay.
(You have to pay a hundred
dollars a year in taxes to
finance this war.)
If his expected profit by the
war will be equal to 0,
and no particular gust or
passions intervene to drive him
from the pursuit of what appears
to be his lasting interest upon
the whole.
-- he will be against the war
and what influence it may happen
to him to possess,
will be exerted on the other
side.
Now, why would his benefit be
zero?
This is rather convoluted
prose, but what Bentham's saying
is,
"If the war is going to be
fought anyway,
I get no marginal benefit from
supporting it.
I might as well oppose it,
or I might as well refuse to
pay taxes in support of
it," right?
And that is the nature of
public goods,
that people can free ride on
their provision because an
economist says the two features
of a public good are they must
be jointly supplied,
everybody has to contribute to
them,
and you can't exclude anybody
from the benefits of them.
Like clean air,
if we create clean air for some
people we're going to create
clean air for all people,
okay?
So people are going to have to
be coerced in the provision of
public goods.
People are going to have to be
coerced to pay for the war.
So that's one example.
Another one that comes up is
the so-called tragedy of the
commons problem.
Suppose you have some common
land, and we'll come back to
talking about this in connection
with Locke's social contract
theory.
God gave the world to mankind
in common, on Locke's story,
so long as much and as good is
available to others in common.
So if you have common land
here's the problem.
You're thinking about grazing
your sheep on the common.
If I put my sheep onto that
common land it doesn't do any
lasting damage,
but if everybody grazes their
sheep on the land and none of it
is allowed to lie fallow,
then it destroys the common,
okay?
So there are too many sheep for
everybody to gaze their sheep on
the land, but any individual
person doesn't have a reason not
to graze his sheep.
This was finally formulated in
a rigorous way by a man called
Garrett Hardin.
The tragedy of the commons that
if you have commons they'll be
destroyed because each person
will do something that makes
individual rational sense but
not collective rational sense.
So this is, again,
it's not exactly the same as
the free-riding problem,
but it's related to the
free-riding problem.
I won't see any reason in the
world why I shouldn't graze my
cow or my sheep on the common,
but when everybody does that we
destroy the common.
It's a bit like walking down
the street with a soda can and
you think,
"Should I take the trouble
to cross the street to put it in
a recycling bin or just throw it
in the trash?"
One Coke bottle,
I mean, what difference one
Coke bottle--it's not going to
make--but if everybody doesn't
cross the street,
the same problem,
okay?
So these are the areas where
there's a disconnect.
There's a disconnect between
individual utility and social
utility, and that is what
creates the need for government.
We will pursue these questions
and much else about classical
utilitarianism next Monday.